[Music]
just a quick note at the very beginning
of this conversation we dive into a
little bit of inside baseball but not to
worry
we come right back around later in the
conversation and explain everything so
stick around and thanks for listening
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
my guest today is none other than
michael dell you can find him on twitter
at michael dell michael is chairman and
chief executive officer of dell
technologies an innovator and technology
leader providing the essential
infrastructure for organizations to
build their digital future transform i.t
and protect their most important
information he is also the author of
play nice but win a ceo's journey from
founder to leader michael is an honorary
member of the foundation board of the
world economic forum and is an executive
committee member of the international
business council in 1999 he and his wife
susan dell established the michael and
susan dell foundation you can find dell
online at dell.com you can find michael
on all social and i'll link to those
at tim dot blog forward slash podcast
but for instance as we mentioned on
twitter michael dell
michael welcome to the show so nice to
see you
great to be with you tim thanks for
having me and i thought we would just
dive right into the action
and begin with a story to pull people
into your life and uh the many
adventures that you've had you open the
new book with some mention of meatloaf
and i'm a huge fan of meatloaf so that
got my attention but there are other
aspects that got my attention could you
please elaborate and tell us the story
of eating meatloaf and why it made it
into the story of your life
yeah well it wasn't meatloaf the the
band or the musician
halfway through the go private
and you know i confront carl icahn
directly face to face eye to eye in his
home
and
go over there to have dinner and i kind
of suspected that he
basically didn't have any plan for the
company
and you know that was my objective was
to understand
did he really have any cards or was he
just
trying to get me to you know raise the
price a little bit and i described this
very dramatic you know moment and i'm at
his house and it's very clear to me that
he didn't have any plan for the company
but it was a fun and exciting moment
about halfway through the go private now
for people who don't have any context
who is carl icahn
let's let's just start with kind of
defining some of the players here and
then we're going to bounce around
chronologically but for those who have
no idea who that is who who is carl
icahn what does he do so he's a
pretty famous financier
sort of corporate raider
green mailer and
general troublemaker who you know kind
of finds his way into
transactions where he can
try to cause trouble and get people to
buy him out
and you know sometimes it works pretty
well sometimes it doesn't to him it's
all a big poker game he showed up in the
middle of our go private he never owned
any of our stock and
found a kind of weasel way into the deal
to
try to make a little bit of money
okay
so
so if we if we freeze frame that in time
there's media coverage with headlines
for instance from fortune the gamblers
behind tech's biggest deal ever but
things didn't start there
and i want to go back to
childhood and the beginnings and then
we're going to jump around
chronologically but where does the title
of the book come from
so play nice but when is something that
my parents used to tell
my two brothers and i whenever we would
go out in the street to play ball
you know they they would tell us played
ice but when and it kind of stuck with
me as a pretty good life philosophy you
know to be
fair to be ethical to be
forthright in in what you're doing you
know in your dealings with others but
also don't forget to win right
so some people just just remember the
play nice part but there's also that
that win part which is also important
but yeah that's uh one of my earliest
memories is
our parents telling us play nice but
when and so it's something that stuck
with me and something we talk a lot
about at dell
and just for people who are wondering or
people who might be saying to themselves
yeah yeah sure okay that sounds nice of
course i must say that as a backdrop to
this
when we were first introduced a few
years ago the mutual acquaintance who
introduced us said to me he said he
really is just the nicest guy imaginable
and his whole family is nice
and that has been my experience and it's
always fascinated me
because i imagine many people listening
will immediately conjure counter
examples in the sense that there are
many ruthless
win at all cost players
and one would imagine that being nice
could be
a handicap if you're constrained
if you're taking certain options off the
table because you view them as unethical
or otherwise that that you would be in a
way tying one hand behind the back when
competing against these other people how
do you think about that
i think life is a is a long journey and
you know your your reputation and your
integrity matter
and i've seen time and time again that
when you do the right thing and you
treat people fairly and and nicely
it comes back around to you in
very positive ways
and it's it's just a you know it's
certainly what i feel comfortable with
but it's also a lot simpler way to live
your life or my perspective if we go
back
again to
i guess your adolescence now this this
is from just doing homework for this
conversation which i always enjoy doing
with people i've met just because it
would seem really creepy otherwise to do
all this internet sleuthing but i have a
context and a pretext for doing it when
i have these interviews and what i'm
looking at here from
an interview is what the journalist
wrote and that is he made a reported
eighteen thousand dollars selling
newspaper subscriptions at age 17. the
secrets to his success trial
subscriptions for new residents at
apartment complexes and condo
communities as well as recruiting
friends to research public records of
new marriage licenses at the county
courthouse so the first thing i have to
ask because you can't believe everything
you read are those statements accurate
is was that part of of what happened in
terms of the the secrets to the success
with the newspaper subscriptions yeah
yeah that's very accurate yeah and how
did you arrive at if you remember
recruiting friends to look at the public
records i i suppose it's just not
something that would immediately occur
to a lot of 17 year olds
i remember exactly what happened i got
this job and
i was a telephone solicitor
and i worked at the houston post in
houston it's now defunct it was merged
with the chronicle and they had a bunch
of us kind of in this big open bullpen
and
we were given sheets of paper that had
just like random phone numbers on them
and you would call the phone numbers
and try to convince people to
buy a subscription to the houston post
newspaper
and
in my first full month i was there i was
the top salesperson i remember that
because i got an award i thought that
was pretty cool but what i figured out
was that
there were a couple things you could do
to sell
newspapers better than anybody else
right and and one of the easiest things
was you just sounded like the people you
were talking to so you know
you just sort of picked up whatever
accent they had i won't do any of those
for you today but but uh i i think i got
reasonably good at that
i also noticed that there were some
trends
of people because you talk to these
people you're like you know striking up
a conversation with them
trends about people that were tending to
buy the newspaper
one was that they were often
getting married
and moving to a new
house or apartment or something like
that sometimes they were just you know
relocating to a new place they were
getting a mortgage something like that
and
i figured out that
in texas as in many states when you want
to get married you have to get a
marriage license and through the freedom
information act you can go to any county
in texas and you can literally go up to
the counter and say
i want to see
all the marriage license applications
for you know this period to that period
and on the application
it says
where you want the marriage license to
be sent to it gives you an actual
address
which is like the perfect address to
send this offer
to
you know get two weeks free for the
houston post and then if you want to
continue it here's the deal and so i
started in harris county which is where
houston is is centered
but then you know there's like 16
surrounding counties so i hired a bunch
of my buddies you know we had apple ii
computers back then and we'd go to these
counties
type in all the names and addresses i
did this massive
direct mail campaign
and yeah that's when i was 16 17 years
old
a lot of fun it sounds like a lot of fun
i mean you've deconstructed the system
and was anyone else doing this or were
you doing this by yourself were you sort
of lone ranger in this approach
i was kind of a lone ranger but i hired
some of my
high school friends to go to some of
these counties because there were 16 of
them and i couldn't really do it all
myself
the other thing that was happening in
houston was it was kind of a boom town
at the time
and sort of like you know in austin now
there's like all these condo complexes
and apartment complexes going up
and you just go up to the you know
person sort of
running the thing and say hey you know
i've got this great offer for all your
new residents
you know can you please put this in the
welcome kit you know and they say sure
so that worked really well so yeah i was
just trying to figure out how to sell a
lot of newspaper subscriptions and
around that time or in your
let's just say early mid-20s were there
any particular
entrepreneurial heroes or figures you
looked up to or tracked closely read
about anything like that
i think
it actually started you know before that
when i was
a kid i mean i saw
you know charles schwab
who started this charles schwab business
which was pretty cool ted turner
fred smith from federal express you know
william mcgowan who had created mci
and then of course bill gates and steve
jobs right who are about 10 years older
than i am and
all of that was super interesting to me
my mom was a stockbroker
you know our family we didn't talk about
the football game or things like that we
talked about the economy and
oil prices and which stocks you know
were interesting and i was really
intrigued by all that and so
those entrepreneurs were definitely
inspirations
you wrote your first book in 1998 so
you've taken a 20-plus year break
on the books and i've i've read that
at the time that you published that
first book you didn't feel comfortable
disclosing
perhaps as much as as you feel
comfortable disclosing now you're
comfortable sharing more and i'm curious
if you would be willing to share a story
or share something that
you weren't comfortable talking about
then that you are comfortable talking
about now
well there's so many things i mean i was
i was not really comfortable with
vulnerability in my
30s when i wrote the first book as you
know in the way i am now so one of the
stories i talk about how i got arrested
uh probably not a story i would have
told
you know 20 years ago but
you know i was i was sort of uh
irresponsible young guy
you know running around in fast cars and
got way too many traffic tickets and
one time i got i got one too many
and uh got pulled over and
literally you know i was taken downtown
at the back of a austin police
department you know cruiser
fingerprinted and everything fortunately
they let me go felt really bad about it
because i always had a lot of respect
for the
police and any any member of the public
service
but um
yeah
there's there's a bunch of stories in
there about you know things that went
wrong and and mistakes made and i wanted
to kind of tell the raw and authentic
story
about how the company you know really
got going and
there were there were plenty of lessons
along the way i mean we had people that
were doing things they weren't supposed
to be doing and i was kind of surprised
by it
but
you know maybe i shouldn't have been
surprised
i'd love to dig into some of the
specifics and talk about the things that
haven't worked or perhaps some of the
mistakes or failures that stick out to
you
are there any particular formative
experiences that fit into either of
those categories that come to mind
yeah i'll i'll give you two that
happened in the both in the late 80s
right about the time you know kind of in
the the year after we went public
and we did a pretty public
face plant as it were
the first one was
we were ramping up our technical
capability and
sort of getting bolder and bolder in
engineering and
we
it was
around the time of the 88 olympics and
we had this big program that we we
codenamed olympics right and uh
and it had
multiple microprocessors and all kinds
of new inventions and
turned out to be
way too aggressive and bold
and it it failed
now i think the lesson from that was to
be a lot more pragmatic and focused in
our innovation
and actually the engineering muscle that
we built
allowed us to in quick succession create
a broad array of products that
were hugely successful and led us to a
lot of growth
one of the other big mistakes we made
around the time
you know now a lot of people talk about
dell's supply chain and
just-in-time inventory and all that
great stuff well it turns out you know
the the the root of that was a horrible
mistake we made in managing our supply
chain
because
there was one of these transitions from
one type of memory chip to another and
we had designed our products with the
older type
and
got caught in a real mess which
you know caused our
you know fledgling company to you know
almost go out of business and you know
stock to go down
because it was really embarrassing but
painful lesson that we learned and that
became the basis of
you know an enormous muscle that we
built around
just-in-time inventory and supply chain
excellence
that served us incredibly well and went
on to fuel all sorts of successes for us
it makes me think
there's of so many examples that come to
mind like uh james cameron and the abyss
where the abyss didn't do very well at
the box office but helped develop the
technology that led
to the newer terminator and terminator 2
right so from the ashes of that
so-called failure there were all of
these technological innovations that
then came to bear on future projects
how do you think about
failure
in the sense that
do you view these various initiatives
product launches etc all as experiments
especially in the early days
were you ever
emotionally
deeply affected by
some of these events or did you maintain
a certain degree of stoicism through it
all
no i was super bummed about it
uh and
and you know unhappy
but it just made me want to go at it
harder
and
i i probably didn't internalize the
lesson in the moment as as much
but
you know there's no such thing as
success by itself right you know failure
is is always an ingredient of success
and
in a in a business when you're doing new
things
it's always
experiment try fail learn do it again
and then you know finally hopefully
maybe you get some success right
but
failure is a is a key ingredient in any
success
when you mentioned this this might seem
off topic but i'm curious
being more vulnerable now or more
comfortable with vulnerability now is
that just a function of age or have you
done certain things have certain other
things changed that have enabled you to
feel comfortable
being more vulnerable
yeah you know i think i think it's a
function of age somewhat and just
maturity and you know also i would say
you know when i started i got off to to
an early start in life and
i found myself in the position where
people were always asking me for things
right it was pretty uncomfortable
because
and so i kind of developed a little bit
of a teflon coating
you know to to distract or
deflect those requests
and at the same time i'm pretty
introverted maybe deeply introverted
right and so all that combined
sort of you know left me in a situation
where i wasn't very disclosing
wouldn't really
explain
you know failures or what was going on
so i think
i think some people you know sort of
looked at the
the origin story or the first you know
decade or so maybe we didn't really
explain you know all the all the
difficulty that that went into
starting a business like this and i
wanted to talk about all that
what were the
toughest periods for you personally with
respect to
the business and the trajectory that it
has had were there any particularly
dark
days that come to mind
and specifically i just want to talk
about
what got you through that period what
happened and how you
coped with it because certainly
with the success
ingredient
you have the the failure component and i
would love to explore that a bit just to
humanize the the entire journey that
you've been on
i would say i'm pretty high on the
determination and grit scale and so
was always looking through to the other
side no matter how
dark it was i mean there were periods
certainly in the early 90s where we had
grown really fast and everything started
to fall apart we kind of went from a
half a billion to two billion
in revenues in a very short period of
time you know a lot of people talk about
you hit the wall at a billion we went
right from 890 million to 2.1 billion in
one year
wow and
everything started to fall apart you
know we didn't have
the systems the processes the people
capital
everything was just
not ready and
there was a period there
during that time where it seemed like
every day every month
the news just kept getting worse and
worse
and
yeah i mean it's a problem you have to
solve but certainly you know when you're
in that
time
you go home and as you try to go to
sleep it's hard to not think about all
the people you're responsible for
their lives their families the
commitments that they've made
and they're counting on you right to
make this work
they move their whole family to
austin
right to
help this company grow and
you know if i if i screw it up it's
going to be not only
really bad but embarrassing and
a great
tragedy certainly during the go private
there were some very dark moments
there was one point where
the board
asked me not to talk to any members of
the management team
makes things hard yeah and i'm the ceo
of the company it was just a short
period of time but
it was
you know pretty weird
and if you go back and look at the press
i mean
there were times when it was totally
unclear what was going to happen
and
yeah those were some pretty dark moments
i mean fortunately you know my my wife
was there supporting me and i had lots
of friends that were encouraging me on
but
yeah what is it uh winston churchill you
know if you're going through hell keep
keep going
[Music]
yeah
that's what we were doing
we'll love to tie that into the
the introvert piece so i also
play the extrovert on occasion but am
deeply introverted but you know my
girlfriend's the opposite she's very
charged and recharged
by being around
in some cases large numbers of people i
get very depleted
i'm curious
through those experiences or just really
in general with the
i imagine the high volume of
communication and the numbers of people
you must interact with
particularly during those crunch times
what type of self-care did you have for
yourself or what did you do
to
recharge
or how did being an introvert
play into that you can tackle that and
it's a number of questions combined into
one but i'm just curious about how you
factor that in if at all
well to to recharge it's it's sleep now
i'm a big fan of sleep
we've had some separate conversations
about that yeah and you know exercise
going on a long walk in the woods
sometimes with my wife sometimes by
myself or or with a friend
but the on stage stuff
it's all
an act right i mean
it's not my natural state of being but
of course you have to do it and it's
important to do it you know to be able
to tell the stories of the company and
describe
what you're doing communicate the value
of what we're bringing to
all these people and get them motivated
and inspired yeah you have to do that
but it's not something i would naturally
do
left to my own devices
yeah
i want to ask you two questions i'll
keep them a little simpler the first is
about that that hyper growth that you
were describing
going from i think it was 890 million to
2.1 billion in a year
something along those lines
in retrospect do you think you should
have constrained that in some way or was
it necessary to just completely blow
things up in order to
to rebuild would you give advice
to
someone in your
similar position
to add constraints of some type or do
something differently
i think on the one hand
we we needed to
balance our growth with also liquidity
and profitability just because we were
running out of capital and our
new cfo that joined us helped me
understand that and figured out
on the other hand if we hadn't gotten
larger
and scaled
we probably would have gone out of
business anyway right so so it was a bit
of a difficult choice that we had to
make and
you know fortunately we're still here to
tell the story
uh i i think to answer your question you
know if we had if we'd only grown from
890
million to 1.3 billion
i think we might have been
too small and on a trajectory
just to be
eliminated in in the industry
and of course we we went on to become
much much larger did you know like 100
over 100 billion this year
but yeah we had to kind of go for it
yeah and it's always hard to rerun the
simulation you know there are definitely
things you would have done differently
but
you know it's worked out pretty well
for the most part you know it seems to
have worked out quite well and
like you said you're here to tell the
tale i would like to next just
ask you to walk us through your thought
process and the process overall for
taking the company private and then
public again because most people
listening will be and some will be very
familiar with this kind of stuff but a
lot of folks will have a passing
familiarity of at least the term going
public and they'll know what an ipo is
but i suspect a a very small percentage
will know anything about then taking a
company private and why someone would
want to do that so could you just walk
us through what happened and how you
thought about it
so the company had gotten you know
quite large
and
the growth started to stall out
and we knew we needed some new horizons
of growth and we started investing
in
new areas like software and services and
security and
started
you know acquiring new companies and
the more we did that the more the
financial investors
kind of didn't like it and they kind of
just kept associating us with
the original product of the company the
pc okay
and this was at a time when
the smartphone and the tablet were
really on the ascendancy and even to the
point where there was kind of this
narrative
out there that oh well you know you're
really not going to need a pc anymore
because you'll do everything on your
phone or you do everything on your
tablet and
we kind of had the view that well those
devices are great but it's going to be
an ad not an or when it comes to these
devices
and
you know when you're making all these
investments and doing all these things
but your stock price is going down
it's kind of depressing right
yeah but at some point it goes down low
enough where
the capitalist in me i can't can't get
that out of me uh
says wow there's like a silver lining
here
that's incredible and that is
we can
buy back our stock
at this really low price
and we can accelerate the transformation
and go faster in fact we're going to buy
back all the stock from the public
shareholders you basically pay a premium
that is you know you pay a price that's
higher than the then current price so
the public investors get
some of the benefit of the
transformation strategy if it's
successful without taking on any of the
risk
and then we as the
owners of the company
you know myself and and silverlake who
join me in the go private
can
really go much faster on the
transformation
we can make investments without having
to think about the quarterly earnings
you know shot clock that is there you
know when you report
every single quarter
and so
i thought it was a relatively
straightforward thing to do it turns out
you know it's a lot harder to buy your
own company back and and we had
the joker showed up carl icahn who uh
sort of make it much more interesting
and difficult
and
yeah it started in august of 2012 and we
finally
completed it in october of of 2013
and
then
you know we just started investing
super aggressively in
research and development hiring more
sales people and it was working
we were generating tons of cash flow
and
we decided
to
sort of quadruple down
and after we done the biggest take
private ever in technology we said let's
do the biggest merger acquisition ever
technology we bought
emc and vmware
and
created
you know
the largest
cloud i.t infrastructure company on the
planet
and
ultimately through a complex series of
transactions we had a tracking stock
we wanted to simplify the capital
structure and and we had transformed the
company in a in a material way and so it
was kind of time to go public again in
late
2018.
okay i have i have some follow-up
questions this is this is extremely
interesting to me because i remember
watching from the sidelines
i remember when this happened but i was
only getting
the you know the headlines but also
getting the interpretation of
the commentators right not the people
actually on the field
first thing i have to ask and i'm
embarrassed that i need to ask this but
what in this context what is a tracking
stock you mentioned tracking stock when
we acquired
emc and vmware combined with them it was
like 67 billion dollars
but we didn't have 67 billion dollars
we had the equity in in dell
we took on
a substantial more debt
and to compensate
the
shareholders
we gave them
a combination of cash
and a tracking stock which tracked see
emc owned an 81
interest in vmware
and so the tracking stock was created
for a portion of that
emc ownership
to compensate the the emc shareholders
tracking stocks are kind of arcane you
don't really see them very often
and
you know the tracking stock appreciated
well
but it's still traded at a substantial
discount to the underlying vmware
shares and
you know a better way to do this was to
align all the interests of shareholders
which is why we ultimately combined with
the tracking stock in late 2018.
so when you were thinking about taking
the company private
and as you went through the process how
did you think about risk and mitigating
risk what were the risks in terms of
downside scenarios or worst case
scenarios and and how did you sort of
mitigate the likelihood of ending up in
those
well when you take a company private
basically you're putting it up for sale
right and anybody can buy it i wanted to
be the person who was going to buy it
and thought that i knew more about it
than anybody else
and i thought it was worth a lot more
than the market thought it was worth
otherwise i wouldn't be buying it right
yeah but a lot of things could have gone
wrong i mean somebody else could have
stepped in
and said well i'm willing to pay a
little bit more and then i would either
have to
top that offer
or
you know at some point get priced out
and of course you know the process can
cause a lot of disruption
it can you know be used by competitors
who can create
fear and uncertainty and doubt in the
market about your business
you know imagine the family members
inside the the company you know reading
about this or hearing about it on tv and
wondering you know what's going on with
this company and
you know during the process a lot of the
downside scenarios played out i mean we
had multiple bidders there were times
when people were speculating about who
was going to run the company and it
wasn't going to be me
it was a pretty messy ugly process
with respect to ultimately going public
and i suppose i should just add his
context so i know
a fair number of public company ceos
and you know more than a few
just hate the shot clock as you put it
they're like hey guys we're trying to
make investments for long-term growth
and innovation
this is
ridiculous right and it bothers them
a lot and
then you know i know the ceos are some
very very large privately held companies
ultimately was the decision to go public
again
necessary because
shareholders needed liquidity is that
how the decision was made
i wouldn't say it was necessary because
shareholders needed liquidity none of
the shareholders have really
accessed liquidity in any material way
yeah but it certainly allowed us to
clean up the capital structure simplify
things pay down debt faster
we just got an upgrade to investment
grade by one of the rating agencies
which
we kind of expected was going to happen
which is great to see it in print but i
would say one of the things we did
during the go private was we reignited
the entrepreneurial spirit of the
company which was its origin
and
i actually believe we've kept that going
even as we're public and so
we're very clear with our investors
that our horizon
is not just
the next 90 days right we're thinking
about you know the medium term and the
and
we've reoriented the business and you
know it's it's working we had 15 growth
this last quarter and at our size that's
substantial growth rate
yeah it's a huge growth rate
was there anyone who
stands out could be more than one person
who was particularly helpful that you're
comfortable sharing during the take
private chapter
of your experience
yeah jamie dimon from jpmorgan chase was
particularly helpful and there's one
story about the combination with emc and
vmware where he comes
with
egon durbin from silver lake and i to
the emc board meeting where we're
basically trying to convince them to let
us buy their company
and
they're asking us all these various
questions and at one point they ask well
you know do you have the money
it's like 67 billion dollars and jamie
just says yeah yeah they have the money
he said it and uh
he has stepped in and helped our company
many many times and
super helpful
thoughtful and been a great friend
i'd love to ask about investments but
maybe not in the traditional sense i'd
love to ask you what
are
one or some of the most worthwhile
valuable investments you've made that
could be an investment of money time
energy
anything at all right and just to give
an example i think
warren buffett when he's asked this
question your best investment he talks
about a public speaking course i believe
it was with the
dale carnegie institute or something
along those lines because it multiplied
so many other skills it was
complementary to so many other things
that he was focused on so it could be
really anything at all
does anything come to mind that would
fit that question
yeah well certainly for me
my best investment by far would be the
thousand dollars that i invested
in starting our company
so that one has turned out to be
certainly one of my all-time best
investments but
you know my mother
macy rest in peace
she recognized
when i was in about the second or third
grade
that i i was stuttering i had a pretty
bad
stuttering problem and she got me a
speech coach
and
you know it seemed like every day i
don't i probably wasn't every day but it
seemed like every day after school i
would go there and the speech coach
would work with me and
after about six months i kind of stopped
stuttering
so it wasn't an investment i made but my
mother kind of knew what i needed at
that particular point in my life and you
know that was clearly a great thing
because it could have held me back
otherwise
how do you think about competition and
i'm leaving that very broad or could you
tell us a story about competition either
will do i'm just curious and this kind
of comes back to one of my original
questions
of
whether or not you
have to change your playbook or opt out
of certain competitions
given you have this north star
of
playing nice
but winning
well there are certain kinds of things
that you just opt out of because you're
not willing to play dirty
yeah and i'd say you see some of that in
in certain countries around the world i
won't name any in particular but you
know who i'm talking about
and so we kind of avoid those things and
you know for me competition is
interesting and often
motivating
i think also it can be limiting
if you're comparing yourself to
competition the competition might not be
very good right
you could totally be setting the wrong
benchmarks right if you're measuring
yourself against
you know a competition that's that's not
really that great and you can also learn
a lot about what not to do from
competition
right
but i actually think
it sounds kind of kind of trite or
quaint you know
you learn a lot more from your customers
than you do from competition and
you know we always talk about having big
years and
designing the company from the customer
back and
solving the unsolved problems of
customers you're not going to get those
things from from the competition
as as much as you will from
a real understanding of
what the customer is trying to do
you have been a true pioneer and i
suppose what
uh what all the kids would call
dtc these days direct to consumer i mean
you you have
tested and tested and refined and
refined and in the beginning certainly
pioneered a lot of approaches i would be
curious to hear
since that the direct consumer model is
uh much more
prevalent now than it was when you
started
what are some of the common mistakes or
things that people miss when they are
novices engaged or trying to engage with
a direct consumer business model
i think there are many
many flavors to it
you know i think
some of the advanced moves are
understanding the information advantage
that you have
with the direct
relationship and connection with the
customer and the way to think about this
is in the simple
sort of retail
versus
direct to consumer or direct to customer
online context
you know if you have
10 000 retail stores
and you're trying to predict what people
are going to go in those stores and buy
yeah you can have like really
sophisticated ai and try to guess that
but ultimately it's just a guess
and you're having to stage and
you know prepare all sorts of things and
anticipate and ultimately it's going to
be wrong and to some degree right and
demands going to change and unexpected
stuff is going to happen
whereas if you have perfect information
and your the quality of your demand
signal is
actually perfect because you're in
direct contact with that customer
you don't need any inventory to prepare
for that you can
use that signal
to
you know feed your supply chain in real
time
and that creates an enormous capital
efficiency
but the information advantage
coupled with the capital efficiency
coupled with the customer intimacy
and
the ability to improve the product
either with telemetry data or feedback
in one form or another
the compounding effect of that is quite
valuable
versus delegating that to a series of
other
parties
why don't more people do that why do
people delegate it out to third parties
what makes it difficult
well i think you're seeing more and more
direct to consumer but you know supply
chains were traditionally
long people had
multiple levels of distributors and
dealers and that sort of thing but now
with digital channels and everything you
know going online you see much more of
that so now it's now it's becoming more
the norm but you think about
you know a product or service today
is continually improving
even once you have it right it's being
upgraded with software and with data
and with ai all the time
and
that's obviously far better than just a
static product so i think more companies
are figuring out even the ones that had
those traditional channels are trying to
figure out
gee how do we create this persistent
connection
with our
customer
so we can be more in touch with their
their actual needs and
you know look i i believe fundamentally
that organizations like like ours and
others
will be successful
if they solve the future problems that
customers have if they don't they'll
just go out of business right so you
have to be in touch with those problems
and you have to
have the capabilities to innovate around
addressing those unmet needs now
customers aren't always going to tell
you exactly what the problem is they
might articulate some
difficulty they're having
a company has to understand
all the ingredients and all the
sort of molecular components that go
into
creating the solution and that's often
where the magic occurs in
product or service creation
is this understanding of all the
ingredients and all the
unsolved problems
so
i have to ask you about this book as a
project
there are million and one things you can
spend your time on you're a busy guy you
are a fully engaged human being with the
world
why
dedicate the time and energy
to
a book project to this book project
a lot has happened in the last decade
from
the go private to the biggest merger
acquisition in history in technology
going public again
transforming the company
again the first book i wrote back in the
90s i really didn't disclose very much
and i wanted to tell the kind of real
authentic story a number of friends
encouraged me to to write a book about
everything that occurred and it was fun
to to go back and and
tell some of the stories about the
origin that i had never talked about
before
as well as kind of explain the real
story of the the struggle to
you know keep the company and transform
it
and is is there anything you really hope
people will come away with after reading
the book
or a particular impact you'd like it to
have on readers
you know i i hope people will take more
risk i mean i i have this belief that
a lot of human potential is sort of left
unrealized because people are
afraid to fail
you know seeking perfection
and
unwilling to
you know experiment and make mistakes
and
you know if you read the story you'll
you'll see that you know at the root
cause of
what is ultimately a very large
successful company
were all kinds of learnings and and
mistakes that that went into it and i
think i think you have to be a little
bit you know willing to
break some rules and you know if you're
always following instructions and doing
what you're told you're not going to
drop out of college and start a company
right
michael i always enjoy our conversations
i am very excited about the book and the
title could not be more accurate as far
as i'm concerned play nice but win is
the title of the book subtitle a ceo's
journey from founder to leader people
can find of course dell online dell.com
at twitter at michaelsdell you're also
at michael dalett instagram facebook
michael s dell linkedin mdl
is there anything else that you would
like to
say any request of the audience any
closing comments you'd like to add
before we wrap up this
conversation no i think you got it i
mean the you know the other things i
talk about in the book are curiosity and
i think you know curiosity
has been a driver for me
i was
interested in in math and electronics
and computers from from an early age
and
that has led me to the path i've i've
been on so
i think
being curious
learning experimenting failing taking
risks
there you go
job i do think
that the combination of stories
sort of allude to
principles and and playbooks that people
can borrow and apply and
moreover that it's possible to win
and be nice while doing it so i really
appreciate you taking time to have this
conversation
and
hopefully we'll be back in austin before
very long but uh thank you for making
the time to
hop on the podcast with me
awesome tim great to be with you thank
you
and to everybody listening we'll have
links to everything in the show notes
all resources as well as links to play
nice but win and everything else at 10.
podcast and until next time
thanks for tuning in
you